تقع محافظه جنين شمالي الضفه الغربيه
وتشكل منبثا للمقاومه الفلسطينيه ومصدر
قلق دائم للاحتلال الاسرائيلي ومدينه جنين
التي يقطن فيها نحو 46,000 نسمه هي مركز
المحافظه وتكتسي مع مخيمها اهميه
الاستراتيجيه نظرا لموقعها اتبعدوا عن
مدينه القدس 75 كلم وعن الناصره 25 كم وعن
حيف 50 كلم وهذا الموقع وهو ما يجعل
الاحتلال لا يليها اهميه القصوى في
استراتيجته العسكريه ويبقى مخيم جنين
للاجئين الذي انشا عامه
53,000 مصدر القلق الاكبر للاحتلال لانه
حاضنه للمقاومه يقتن في المخيم الذي تبلغ
مساحته نحو كيلومتر مربع 16
مما يجعل الكثافه السكانيه فيه عاليه جدا
في عام 2002 اجتاحت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مخيمه في سمتها الصوره الواقي
لقي الاحتلال مقاومه شديده خلال عمليه
الاجتياح التي كلفته كثيرا اذ قتل 50 من
جنوده وقد اعتقد الاحتلال انه قضى على
المقاومه في مخيم جنين بهذه العمليه لكن
المخيم لملم جراحه بسرعه وعاد ليؤرق قوات
الاحتلال وتنشط في المخيم قوات تابعه
لفصائل فلسطينيه عده منها الجناح العسكري
لحركات فتح كتائب شهداء الاقصى لواء
الشهداء وحركه الجهاد الاسلامي ممثله في
كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس وما يميز
عمل هذه الفصائل في هذا المخيم هو
والالتحام والتازر والتنسيق مع نسبه عاليه
من الاستقلال في تنفيذ عملياتها ضد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي